[Música]
oi gente
vou perdoar o meu meu anfitrião nome da
empresa prossiga está é a máscara estou
muito feliz de estar aqui hoje faz
questão de faz questão de faz questão de
prestar aqui o meu tributo à hora por um
cara que tornou isso aqui possível um
grande amigo um cara que quer um exemplo
pra mim em muitos sentidos e de forma
que eu tenho que parabenizar e agradecer
muito pelo pelo convite de estar aqui
hoje e eu falar podendo da unisuam uma
expressão que eu admiro e respeito é é
um motivo de muita honra porque eu tenho
certeza que o público que tá ali fora o
público provavelmente está nos
assistindo altivo é público que que se
está investindo em educação see está
investindo na própria formação é porque
tá pensando em tomar grandes decisões de
dar grandes passos na vida e eu tenho
certeza que os maiores e melhores passos
que a gente da nossa vida eles vêm logo
depois das decisões mais difíceis que a
gente toma na nossa carreira então é um
prazer enorme falar de de como eu
aprendi a dar esses passos não só dentro
da chuteira como para fora da china e ao
longo de toda essa minha jornada à
frente da procissão
bom é meu eu nasci numa numa família
aqui que me deu tudo que eu precisava
sim a minha casa eu nasci em jacarepaguá
a minha família possuir bem estruturada
eu tive eu tive a oportunidade de
estudar em bons colégios em boas
faculdades e ao contrário dos meus pais
eu acho que a minha mãe pela assembléia
de pina tem que pagar o estudo que ela
achava que era digno da do tamanho dos
sonhos dela
meu pai veio pro pro rio com a mãe e
cinco outros irmãos
é também para lutar pelo espaço dele no
mercado é e assim mesmo numa casa com
tantos bons exemplos e conselhos
a gente muitas vezes é difícil você
assimilar a mensagem o conselho de amor
e carinho que que os seus pais decidam e
e você de fato só aprende quando aquele
negócio toca na pele e mas eu posso
dizer eu acho que a primeira vez o que
eu vou dizer isso todo mundo quando
entra no no mercado de trabalho ver que
cara difícil alguém tirar um espaço
difícil a oportunidade vim de graça em
algum momento você você realiza que
qualquer grande conquista que vem até na
vida só vai vir pelo seu próprio esforço
pelo seu próprio mérito ea gente pode
diante das dificuldades gastar o tempo
que a gente quiser tentar achar um
culpado por qualquer coisa que se
apresente para gente como um desafio mas
no fim do dia a responsabilidade é nossa
e aí óbvio que essa mensagem ela chega
mais cedo ou mais tarde para as pessoas
não importa mas ela chega e ela cobra
caro mas eu tenho certeza que todo mundo
que que lembra o que está passando por
isso agora é percebeu que fica
martelando na cabeça uma frase que
provavelmente o conselho de muitos pais
aqui presentes lá fora de que
independentemente de quem é a culpa a
responsabilidade é nossa
responsabilidade a sua por perseguir
seus objetivos e eu na cultura que eu
precisava dentro de casa
eu acho que é a primeira vez que eu vou
falar disso dessa forma eu tive na minha
realidade pessoal um desafio por ter
nascido com uma
uma uma condição congênita chamada
crânio estenose né que é uma doença que
provoca o fechamento das mulheres de um
recém-nascido de forma aqui se eu ficar
vou caminhar e de perfil vocês vão
perceber hoje eu falo isso com alguma
naturalidade depois de sofrer um bocado
com isso mas pelo fechamento da mulher e
do recém nascido da cabeça cresce de
forma desproporcional
isso representa um risco relevante para
a formação do do bebê e ea minha família
com toda dedicação e todo o amor me
colocou na mesa de cirurgia com oito
meses por uma cirurgia que desculpa
gente mas é menos jogos mortais é a
furadeira no crânio da criança passa a
ser a retiro tampo do crânio e muita
gente está pensando em colocar alguma
coisa de volta não não coloca é e esse
negócio pra mim gente assim que hoje eu
falo com alguma naturalidade foi é e do
o outro apresentador aqui duas vezes
antes de mim desculpa mas falou que de
fato cada um sabe o seu problema cada um
sabe a sua dificuldade e aquilo para uma
criança por um próprio adolescente
depois que você faz quando você vê um
moleque correndo querendo perto basta
passar a mão na cabeça do cara
e pra mim isso era caro do mundo assim
eu não queria explicar aquele negócio
ninguém eu tinha um buraco eu tenho até
hoje um buraco no crânio é e eu não
queria ter que explicar aquele negócio
de ninguém ea minha família sempre me
apoiou muito sempre esteve do meu lado
sempre me estendeu a mão sempre me me
olhou e me recebeu com carinho o afeto
com com um todo o amor que eu precisava
só que no fim do dia você está no seu
quarto sozinho desliga a televisão e
você dorme contando as vezes que você
tem que explicar porque tem um buraco no
campo da sua cabeça é e de novo assim
num e colocam em posição de julgar o
problema de ninguém esse foi o meu
grande desafio o desafio que
independentemente de quem fosse a culpa
e não era culpa do meu pai da minha mãe
da foi um acaso genético eu tenho uma
irmã que esses vão dizer que a mais
bonita que eu mas certamente não é
é tiete que nasceu sem isso eu nasci e
de novo é culpa de ninguém não foi um
bife à mãe comeu-o ou qualquer coisa que
é que meu pai bebeu que me fez na
sequência ou simplesmente nasci e eu ia
dormir todos os dias
podia ficar o tempo que quiser
procurando culpado não tinha
responsabilidade no fim do dia
era minha de encarar o próximo dia e eu
tive que explicar para outras pessoas eu
explicaria e é uma outra coisa que eu
aprendi com isso tudo foi que
independente de onde a angústia de um
filho aperte independente da dor que o
filho sinta é no pai nos pais
a dor no coração dos meus pais sofreram
muito comigo tenho certeza até quando
eles puderam mais uma vez depois de
muito esforço é me levar para a segunda
cirurgia no momento super emocionante
foi com a mesma equipe médica que operou
com oito meses de vida é pra fazer uma
cirurgia reparadora e hoje eu tenho essa
testa disponível maravilhosa aqui de
segunda mão mas mas eu eu é o segundo
atentado que eu tirei foi de que na dor
dos pais sempre aperto no coração e é um
pouco da relação e aí tentando trazer um
pouco já pra pra mim é o meu projeto de
vida própria missão que eu escolhi
encarar depois de descer de ter uma
trajetória é pode muita luta muita
perseverança dentro da chuteira mas
quando eu abrir empresa eu nunca quis
ter uma empresa sempre que chega a
desenvolver coisas legais e grandes
projetos é uma empresa muito parecido
com isso se pendente de onde seja a dor
independente de onde esteja o problema é
aberta no nosso coração pode ser cara o
cara do cara que está imprimindo folha
demais a impressora pode ser o teu sócio
que por falou besteira o cara pode ser
com um grande
é uma pessoa com quem você contava que
deixou na mão no fim das contas essa
jornada de três anos aproxima ensinou
que eu só me provou na verdade que tudo
aquilo que eu que eu aprendi e eu de
fato só consegui enxergar tudo que tinha
vivido com a minha condição é pessoal
depois de detido essa jornada e te visto
que é pra para tantas outras pessoas que
hoje a gente consegue ajudar na prost
elas vende de faculdades diferentes
origens diferentes ela se forma em um
lugar diferente elas carregam formações
diferentes convicções diferentes ea
gente tem que tem que conseguir impactar
o caminho delas e e provocar
transformação assumindo a
responsabilidade muitas vezes muito mais
de forma proativa e eu garanto que as
principais feito as principais
conquistas a gente com a gente consegue
quando é a gente não é estimulado quando
a gente é procura o nosso desconforto
assumindo a responsabilidade pelo nosso
crescimento inclusive quando as coisas
parecem que vão bem e para isso
acontecer de forma que você não não viva
é pelas frustrações que vão acontecer o
tempo todo de forma é sofrível
a única forma de você é você caminhar e
avançar e atacar essas frustrações com
com com força e capacidade de mudar sua
realidade é a quebrando absolutamente
todas as expectativas que você tem
mesmo em relação aos o melhor sócio pode
ser que em algum momento só tem um filho
deixe de priorizar o negócio pode ser o
cara que você achou que fosse fechar
negócio com o time simplesmente mude de
idéia e compra da concorrente
pode ser que um sócios eu desista de de
tomar para ele as dificuldades da
empresa ao seu lado e queira transmitir
para você a responsabilidade por
resolver os problemas dele também
e quando você quando você realiza isso
quebra simplesmente todas as
expectativas que você tem sobre tudo à
sua volta é a única forma de você
conseguir se mover para frente é sem que
a
frustrações e os desafios que machuquem
de fato porque essa jornada cobra caro
cobra caro mesmo assim como eu tive meu
problema na infância e todo mundo aqui
teve os seus e a conta chega para todo
mundo chega em momentos diferentes de
forma diferente é ea gente não tem muita
opção senão é seguir em frente
outro ponto que eu acho que é muito mais
prático e pragmático e que eu e que o
valorizo muito na nas minhas relações
inclusive com parceiros como arapuan
é essa visão sistêmica eu poderia chamar
de responsabilidade sistêmica também
porque a quem enxergar a as a forma como
as coisas se comunicam e os impactos se
desdobram na rede de de de interface da
da sua vida da sua empresa e isso vale
não só para quem é empreendedor para
quem tem o próprio negócio mas para
qualquer pessoa que está desenvolvendo a
sua carreira afinal de contas se for
olhar em volta as empresas são cada vez
menores as habilidades exigidas são cada
vez mais de ponta é é demandado cada vez
mais habilidades interpessoais para a
resolução de problemas complexos ea
complexidade está exatamente do ponto de
vistas no ponto de vista sistêmico das
corporações e do do mundo dos negócios
de forma geral não se você tem uma visão
restrita ou o ou limitada ao seu abc
coisas que você faz no seu dia a dia
você está correndo sérios riscos de
simplesmente não se mais necessário é
importante dentro de qualquer estrutura
dentro do projeto que tenha pela frente
e ao longo do tempo é você vai perceber
que é preciso também ter coragem coragem
pra lá tendo enxergado de forma
sistêmica o que é realmente importante
para você ou para a companhia que você
representa o defende é a coragem para se
posicionar coragem pra apresentar o que
você realmente acredita na forma como
deve ser feito é isso é um é sem dúvida
um exercício diário também de conseguir
é de ter coragem dia consigo mesmo
desafiar os seus próprios limites e as
suas
mas as suas próprias barreiras internas
e como estou fazendo aqui hoje e disse
para vocês pela primeira vez abrindo ao
que foi pra mim tão importante e aqui
sem querer perder tempo com muitos
clichês mas é uma palavra que todo mundo
gosta de usar para quem quer que tenha
um projeto grande e desafiador ao longo
da vida
resiliência serve com um único e simples
objetivo é de você tendo quebrado todas
as suas expectativas e enxergando a
forma como os seus caminhos se comunicam
com as suas possibilidades de você
simplesmente entender que a vida não vai
trazer para você as coisas no tempo e na
forma como você imaginou se o desafia
seu projeto é seu você tem que estar
simplesmente garantindo que se depender
de você um negócio acontece e na forma
como como oportunidade aparecer você
está pronto para atacar e resiliência
pra mim é simplesmente isso é garantir
que no melhor do seu esforço no melhor
dos da sua dedicação
você tá é pronto para alcançar os seus
objetivos independentemente das
circunstâncias eu acho que é disso é que
o brasil precisa cada vez mais de uma
geração que seja capaz de determinar seu
futuro de construir seus caminhos e
alcançar seus objetivos
independentemente das circunstâncias é e
eu só não sei quanto tempo eu só posso
agradecer pelo pelo convite está aqui
hoje a oportunidade de expor algo que
pra mim é tão especial é num evento
promovido por um cara que a não
deixa dúvidas pra ninguém de que de que
tem as melhores intenções os melhores
valores e está promovendo aqui porque de
fato é importante para ele
só posso agradecer a esses minutos de
dados do tempo de vocês pela atenção
pelo carinho como foi recebido por toda
a equipe
e muito obrigado pelo tempo de vocês